what do you love most about what you do
it doesn't have to be most what are all
the things you love well how great is it
to love your job so many people don't
that in itself is amazing
oh I mean I love acting itself I think I
touched on it I love those moments that
are out of control that are completely
surprising when their energy on it takes
on a life of its own and no matter what
you've prepared it just becomes whatever
it needs to be I love that I love the
feeling on cess I love being with the
crew I love sitting in makeup in the
morning when everyone's drinking tea and
just working I love getting up early in
the morning when no one else is up and
it's so quiet on the way to work I mean
they're not always glamorous trust me
but I don't think I could ever live in a
really big house cuz I've spent so much
time bands and trailers it always comes
down to the people it comes down to that
collaboration that is really the most
exciting satisfying thing and it's
always different and no one very rarely
do people know each other before
something starts and it's unit
everyone's always nervous and it's so
focused and intense and everyone gets to
know each other really quickly in the
most unbelievable way we have a show
starting today on Netflix called
unbelievable excellent good plug another
little admission and I admitted this to
Tony while we were working but there
were many times where I had everything I
needed in a scene and I made her do it
again just because it's so much fun to
watch her work I would say no we're
going again no we're going again I get
to watch this I get to be the first
person to see this ever